okay
welcome to rochester district council's
remote council meeting
of the 23rd of february 2021
and a warm welcome also to anybody
watching us via the live stream
i shall take item one on the agenda
apologies for absence
repo apologies have been received in the
office from councillors canal
and wilson are there any more members
no thank you agenda item two minutes of
the meeting held on the 16th of february
2021 members are you happy for me to
sign these in due course
um that's the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 16th
of february and i assume agreement
unless
anyone clicks on the raised hand icon
there are no such indications thank you
members that has been agreed
agenda item three declarations of
interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
councillor wilkinson thank you chairman
um
i'd like to declare a pecuniary interest
in relation to item 9
1.4 the arg grants by virtue of the fact
that i currently have an application
sitting with rochester council
thank you thank you councillor wilkinson
members i shall take agenda item four
announcements
from the paid chairman so from the
chairman
leader or head of paid service there are
none
the leader of the council would also
like to make an announcement council
woodson
thank you chairman i think um we agreed
i wouldn't be making an announcement at
this point okay thank you councillor
woodson councillor hookway
you'd like to speak
yes yes chairman um yes sir sir
my hand was a little bit slow it's
relating to
declarations of interest like
councillor wilkinson i need to declare
an interest in relation
to the same matter because i have an
application in as well
thank you councillor hookway
members will take item 5 on the agenda
public questions and member questions on
notice
of which there are none agenda item 6
business from last meeting members does
anyone have any questions relating to
the business from the council meeting
held on the 15th of december 2020
none indicated thank you item agenda
item 7 to note the minutes of the
executive and committee meetings held
between the period first of december
2020 to the 9th of february 2021
are these noted members and i will
assume agreement unless anyone clicks on
the race hand icon
no such indication thank you members
agenda item 8 to consider any reports
from the executive and committees
to council of which there are none
agenda item nine report on urgent
decisions
these noted members i will assume
agreement unless anyone clicks on the
raised hand icon
no such indication thank you members
that's been noted
agenda item 10 report of the leader on
the work of the exec
executive
council councillor wooten
thank you chairman members i'm pleased
to provide an update
for information purposes on business
dealt with by the executive since the
last full council meeting
in december 2020 at its meeting on the
3rd of february
the executive executive noted the
quarter 3
20 20 21 revenue budget and capital
position
set out in the financial management
report
it also approved a budget of 20 000
pounds
to appoint external legal advisors to
provide
advice on contract strategy and
preparation of legal documentation
on the waste collection and street
cleansing contract
in line with this decision the
three-month extension was agreed
at the end of july 2022
on the existing waste collection and
street cleansing contracts
to allow sufficient time for a
procurement process
to be undertaken portfolio holder
decisions which have been taken
have been leased
a section of the council-owned asset
known as ashington pavilion
to washington parish council to use as
an
office space meeting room and public
conveniences
for a period of seven years and an
annual rent of 2
500 pounds also agreed
that a response be submitted to the
government's supporting housing delivery
and public service infrastructure
consultation
within the prescribed time period
and finally entered into the statement
of common ground
with castle point borough council as
relating to the castle point
local plan thank you chairman
thank you accounts of the wooden members
i shall now take agenda item 11 motions
on notice
of which there are none
agenda item 12 setting the council tax
2021 walk 22
council britain could i ask you to
introduce the report please
that's kind of you chairman thank you
very much chairman this is my first
budget as leader of this conservative
administration
the budget pressures under which local
government operates remains significant
and this authority continues to look
closely
at opportunities to make efficiency
savings
and generate new sources of revenue
this is not only in response to the
removal of government grants
but also to deal with significant cost
increases
arising from inflationary and
demographic pressures
as well as the impact of cobit 19.
our business plan sets out the high
level priorities that this council will
work towards
over the medium term which are
being financially sustainable using
early intervention to manage demand
on our services maximizing our assets
and enabling communities
following approval at full council in
september 2020
the council and its development partner
gb partnerships
have entered into a contract to deliver
the council's asset delivery program
this exciting program will see the
regeneration of key sites
across the rockford district providing
the modern
and flexible spaces that our staff and
residents
will need in the future alongside this
the council's connect cultural and
transformation program
will ensure members and staff can
operate
as 21st century public servants and will
improve our digital interface
with residents and meet expectations of
quality
customer service despite the challenges
faced over the last year
we have continued to deliver excellent
services to our residents
some key achievements include
partnership working via the community
response hub
which has seen health and well-being
partners come together
with volunteers to support a range of
resident needs
during the pandemic partnering with
chess
that's the church's homeless emergency
support scheme
to relieve homelessness and related
hardship
paying out well over 20 million pounds
of covered nineteen related grants to
around
two thousand businesses in the rochford
district
launching the reopening high street
safely and business
adaptation fund schemes to support
businesses to reopen
in a covered secure way
providing self-isolation support
payments to over
70 per cent of applicants putting us
amongst the top rates
in the country supporting fusion
lifestyle
to successfully reopen the council's
leisure sites in a code 19
secure phased approach after the
lockdown
being placed seventh in the league for
recycling
out of more than 350 authorities across
england maintaining an
unqualified set of financial accounts
and value for money
opinion from our external auditors
awarding grants to voluntary groups
working across the district
to enable them to deliver initiatives
that improve our strong
community resilience which exists across
our district
achieving an estimated 900 000 pounds of
savings to the nhs
and wider society along with just over
70
housing hazards being removed or reduced
as a result of the work
of the private housing team
agreeing rochford's carbon neutral
policy an action plan on approving a
disposable plastic policy
which sets out how rockford will reduce
its use of plastics
and support others to do the same
facilitating rainy windmill volunteers
to deliver windmill wednesday's
videos on social media while it remains
closed due to the pandemic
supporting health walk to help residents
moving by resuming kobe 19 safe
health walks in september
and finally working in partnership with
active ethics
through their activity heroes campaign
which recognizes
local heroes who have helped keep the
county safe
and active during this difficult year
chairman and colleagues the list is
endless
and is way in excess of those long
established services we deal with as a
council
day in and day out for example
development control waste collection
open space maintenance street cleaning
leisure services business support
housing
community support car parking management
to name
but a few as a responsible council
we will continue to look at areas where
costs can be reduced
or income generated however in 2122
there is a need to increase council tax
by 2.1
to help fund the financial pressures
that the district is currently facing
this equates to an increase of 10 pence
per household per week on a banned d
property i repeat an increase of 10
pence
per household per week on a band-aid
property
it must be remembered though that we
should celebrate
by being a debt-free council with no
loan interest to pay we are addressing
our projected budget gap
and providing capital investment in our
district
creditable achievements indeed and the
envy
of many other local authorities
the proposal is to set rockford district
council's tax
for bandy property at 240 pounds
21 pence per year the breakdown of
annual council tax for a band d property
would be asics county council proportion
1204 pounds 92 pence
essex county council social care levy
135 pounds 99 pence
essex county fire and rescue 73 pounds
89 pence
essex police fire and crime commissioner
208 pounds 53 pence
average town parish councils 52 pounds
25 pence and the rochford district
council share
240 pounds 21 as i said earlier
so the total average council tax for a
band d
property 20 21 22
would be 1 915 pounds 79
an increase of 35 pounds and 16 pence
that equates to 1.9
it needs to be remembered that the
rochford district council share of the
council tax
is actually less than 50 15
of the total but we are the billing
authority
for all of the preceptors
in conclusion chairman although these
remain difficult financial times
gotcha district council remains
committed to providing an excellent
excellent services to our residents and
partners with this in mind
we will be doing all we can to deliver
innovative
and high quality services
chairman i commend the rocha district
council tax for members approval
as set out in the recommendations at
item 5
of the report but before i pass over to
you chairman if i may
i should like to refer to the monitoring
officer angela law
who will talk us through the additional
item in the
items in the addendum at item five
on my channel thank you thank you
councillor woodson
uh angela
thank you chairman firstly um i'd like
to give my apologies to yourself and
members members
angela is muted chairman
please
angela do you wish to carry on
chairman angela is muted yes chairman i
have to
be muted and share your yeah um
councillors angela is sharing my
microphone so that there's no feedback
i'd ask you to be quiet so that we can
all hear us speak please
thank you jim uh chairman yes i'd like
to be my voice to yourself
and your members an addendum was sent
out just prior to this meeting as
there's been an admission
to the recommendation um
uh there is an addendum to item 12
with four additional
bullet points to the recommendation
through youtube i'm happy to read the
recommendations for if you would allow
adjournment for 10 minutes
to allow members to read
chairman sorry chairman you're muted
members
i shall adjourn the meeting for 10
minutes in order for members
to read the addendum to item 12 which
you'll receive
by email this afternoon i shall also
arrange
for the addendum to be shown on the
screen
which is coming up soon
thank you members i shall come back to
you in
10 minutes
foreign
let's get it working alpha yes
yep good
that's a bit of a blinding obvious
question really wasn't it
hmm
members thank you for your patience
hopefully you've had sufficient time
uh to read the additional items um
as per the addendum um uh
the recommendation 5.1 on 12.3 and 12.4
have already been moved which include
the additional items as per the addendum
by councillor wootton
um do i have a second to please
council smith
council smith
pardon um i'm i'm happy to second this
chairman
thank you council smith um
members i shall now open this up to
general debate um anybody wishing
to speak um with counselor eaves please
thank you chair um just a little bit
concerned that we've had
something which really we would normally
want to have
a uh an amount of time outside the
meeting to be able to cross-reference
something as
potentially quite um complicated to
understand
um to be presented with it at this point
in the meeting
it seems to me um to
rather prejudice the voting in that
a lot of us if we're honest will have to
abstain
um and i think it's a bit um
a bit of a miscalculation to present it
to council at this late stage
thank you thank you council reeves for
your comments does anybody else wish to
make any comments
no one
remember this counselor smith you'd like
to speak
uh that thank you chairman i think yeah
i i do understand what uh cancer eve
has said but i would just like to point
out
that the recommendation that
is uh before us is essentially a
statement of fact
or an explanation of how a
particular calculation is made um
i i can appreciate that there are
aspects to the
um the setting of the council tax that
are controversial but effectively they
were dealt with last week i
i think to my mind the only question
would be if there is anything factual
wrong in the figures that are stated
or the the the basis of the calculations
that have been made and i i certainly
don't have any any trouble with this at
all
thank you chairman thank you council
smith
um naomi would you like to speak
um thank you chairman yeah i was just
going to echo and what councillor smith
um
said in the um it's essentially a
factual calculation of how the council
tax amount set out in the report have
been arrived at
the recommendations themselves don't add
anything new
to the report the appendices that they
refer to were
already referred to within the body of
the report they just were not referenced
as specific
recommendations but there's no change to
the way the council tax has been
calculated
um to the way it's been done in previous
years so i just like to sort of add that
um assurance to members that there's
nothing new or different that's been
added to this report by that by that
addendum thank you
thank you for the explanation naomi
lucas
um council stanley
thank you chairman um i'm sure that
uh has been just noted that uh
from uh naomi that uh the calculations
are are the same as what they were
previous years uh i'm sure um
but i do think that in
essence it would be nice to have this
beforehand uh even though i do believe
it's it's probably correct
on the on the assumption that they they
know
obviously you know what they're doing
and it's been like this for several
years but
it would be nice to have it some time
beforehand rather than
presented on the night thank you thank
you councillor stanley
members i cannot see anybody else
wishing uh to speak
on this item i shall therefore
put it to the vote the recommendation
at 5.1 including the additions as per
the addendum
has been proposed by council wooden and
seconded by council smith
those members who cannot raise their
blue hand
i shall ask them individually
if they would like to have a recorded
vote
councillor mrs carter would you like a
recorded vote
thank you chair yes i would thank you
councillor hazelwood
would you like a recorded vote
no thank you
councillor ionu
would you like a recorded vote
no thank you thank you council merrick
would you like a recorded vote no
chairman
thank you council merrick um members
everybody else can erase their hand icon
um if anybody would like a recorded vote
to be taken please click on
click on the raise hand icon um
to indicate your wish for a
recorded vote please
members there will not be a recorded
vote
members could i ask therefore
are they all hand thank you members
could i ask them for those people who
wish
to vote for the recommendation to
indicate please
oh sorry members my apologies
i shall go to the four members who
cannot raise their hand
first um uh
counselor mrs tony carter
can you indicate whether you're in favor
of
the uh recommendations against
our abstain thank you i abstain
thank you councillor hazelwood
are you in favor of the recommendation
thank you
councillor i owed him i'm in for the
recommendation
thank you and council merrick
thank you all other members please
indicate
whether they're in favor of the
recommendations please
members if i could ask you now to lower
your raised hands please
members those members who wish
to vote against the recommendations
please indicate
thank you members and those who wish to
abstain
please indicate
members um those recommendations have
been accepted 27 votes for none against
and seven abstentions thank you remember
members we shall now take item 13 on the
agenda this is a local council tax
support scheme 2021
stroke 22 council simon smith could i
please ask you to introduce this report
council smith thank you chairman um
this report is exceptionally similar to
the report that you saw last year the
principal
change is that an inflationary increase
has been
included for 21 22.
um chairman this is perhaps not what
might be best described as one of our
most
accessible documents at 196 pages
long but it is the policy and a legal
document
rather than a a user guide but i can
assure members that
on the website there is a significantly
significantly condensed
um version which is which is much more
accessible
for uh members of the public or that
that might
wish to access this scheme um
i am quite happy to move it for
recommendation chairman
thank you councillor smith do you have a
second to councillor smith
councillor laureen shaw i was second
that chairman thank you
thank you councilman mrs shaw
members i shall open this up to debate
um
counselor michael hoy
thank you chairman i'm sure most members
who know me know that i would always
love to speak on
this item and i think i do so every year
so i'm sure
members who know me know what i'm now
going to do um
i i have some problems with this um
policy and as i've raised previously
it's to do with the
the minimum income floor for those
members who might not be
completely familiar with with this
policy it assumes that
there's an assumption built into
the calculations that self-employed
people
will earn the minimum wage or the
national living wage
at 35 hours a week now clearly this
isn't always the case
there are exceptions to this built in
within the policy
um for startups for instance and i
understand from
talking to naomi lucas this year that
there's
been some extensions to this on hardship
however
i would like to point out that central
government have removed
the minimum income floor from
calculations in relation to universal
credit
for the moment and it's likely to remain
so for the next year as well i
understand it might well be in the
budget
to to do that for another year so my i'm
proposing an amendment to the motion to
remove
reference to the minimum income floor
which is essentially paragraph 29
8.0 um
i believe i have a second for that
uh yes yes chairman that's councillor
hookway i will be second in that uh
council of hoy's motion thank you
thank you um councillor hawkway um
members we have a proposal and a second
for an amendment
um councillor hoy um just to be
perfectly clear could you please
reaffirm um the uh exact
amendment you require please thank you
chairman i'll just
i will double check it as i speak to you
to make sure i've got the right
paragraph but i did write it down
earlier
but as you suggest it's best not to make
an error in something like this
and to confirm it which i've
on my pdfs so they'll be there in a
moment
highlighted council you you do you
you wish to amend the recommendations
that what you're saying yeah the
recommendation is for the full
is for this i'm moving an amendment to
remove
29.0 which is
the reference to minimum income floor so
it's paragraph which starts on page
13.67 of our report or page
64 of the actual policy i believe
that's where it starts
oh
are you coming back to me
uh sorry um counselor i thought i had
come back to you yes i was confirming
that there's no
i'm i'm proposing an amendment which has
been seconded by
council hawkway to remove paragraph 29.0
which starts on page 13.67 of the report
and i think page 64
of the policy okay
members we shall debate that amendment
as uh as put forward by councillor hoy
and uh seconded by council hawkway
um council council smith
thank you chairman as uh council
uh as pointed out he is a a creature of
habit and
uh he is quite right he's raised this on
on a number of occasions uh we we
believe that this section does allow
fairness with
those that are employed and i i've got
to now
get given that i sort of had a
foresight that this question might be
coming up um i i do have an answer which
i'll read out if that's
if that's all right just the reason why
this decision
this item is in there please carry on
council smith thank you
um it's not possible to quantify the
cost of removing the minimum
income floor known as the myth
unfortunately there is no identifier in
our system to show where the
myth has been applied as this is just a
consideration
which forms part of the cat of the
calculations for the
cts of a self-employed applicant
under the terms of the scheme we would
need to manually check
every self-employed claim that we are
currently paying
and there are those that have previously
been self-employed
and go through the calculation of the
claim to establish
whether the myth has been applied
under the terms of our policy we can at
our discretion
extend the startup period or allow a
further startup period
where one has already been given this
gives us particular
flexibility to look at cases on an
individual basis
we've been particularly mindful of this
during the pandemic period
only a small number of experienced staff
within the benefits team
deal with self-employed cases they're
all aware
of the use of discretion as far as the
myth
is concerned and they do this
consistently
in line with the policy allowing
extensions
and new start-up periods where
appropriate
if anyone feels they've been unduly
affected by the myth
being applied then we would look at
those cases on an
individual basis therefore chairman
i i don't feel it is appropriate to
support the proposed um amendment thank
you
thank you council thank you council
smith councillor hawkway
thank you chairman um the reason why i
support um
council ahoy's um amendment uh
amendment uh with with his motion is um
because uh it's a simple
uh matter to uh to
alter this um and
also um this is something that comes up
every year
and because it comes up every year the
council has the opportunity
if it fills so
um to reverse any decision that it might
have made the previous year
is not something that is um going to be
set
in stone forever so um
bearing in mind the um
the situation that we have found
ourselves in over the
last year and there has been a number of
uh
issues um which people have
found particularly amongst the
self-employed to do with hardship
and with their earnings this could be
something that
could be as well as being an
actual benefit it would also show
this particular part of our community
that the council
is really thinking about
those individuals who
are in the position of being
self-employed and this is much
broader uh spectrum now uh because of
the
um the various different types of
employment
with the gig economy and stuff like that
and self-employed people
can be on very low incomes and
and so this would this would definitely
be a help
to many of the um the lower
um income form of self-employment that
we find ourselves
uh with um at this this moment in time
so um as i say you know the council
could be um
quite bold and generous and and back
this motion
um and if they felt that it wasn't
something that uh
was working or there was some issues to
do with
how it has been administered um in a
year's time the council could
change its mind and reverse it but uh
but
you know you you will never know how
how much of a benefit this will be
unless you actually implement it
thank you thank you councillor hookway
um council wilkinson you're indicating
you wish to speak
but we are debating uh the amended
motion as put forward by councillor hoy
and uh seconded by council hookway do
you wish to speak
on that amended motion uh there's one
point i want
one question i wanted to ask chairman
but before i do so
um i am conscious of that i want to do
initially i put my hand up to speak on
the main
substantive motion if this motion made
the motion
fails would you allow me to speak again
on the on the main motion
yes i will counter will consider thank
you chairman in that case i have one
question if i may of councillor smith
if i just understand correctly what
you've just said uh
paragraph 29a2 uh talks about the
two-year startup period if i understand
it correctly is is it a case that
the council will look at applicants uh
on an individual case-by-case basis and
we
we have got the capability within the
scheme to extend past that two-year
period if the um if if the grounds
um are there so in other words we're not
going to stick to two years rigidly
we can extend past that two-year period
if we want to
council smith can you respond to that
please yes
yes thank you
thank you council smith council stanley
thank you thank you chairman uh just one
other point
uh and i'm just referring has already
been referred to as the
self-employed but also the the
low hours uh where where
people are not necessarily employed
under an employment contract
but under an hour's contract so you know
that
we could still have people with low
hours would that
is that still uh um something which the
council were looking at as
as well as this or can be looked at as
well as the self-employed
thank you councillor stanley uh council
smith can you respond to that one
i'm not i'm not sure i've fully got the
gist of the
question um because i think we were
moving away
from um from self-employed
just to put just to put it in the same
frame is
um on how can i put this
self-employed as we all know is not is
not necessarily a contract with
with a business uh it's their own
business and
and with a lot of businesses at the
moment
um they are a lot of people are on
short term if you like short term uh
hours
or or what whatever that may be it
it it somehow relates to the
self-employed because they are basically
self-employed they've got no guarantee
of work or anything
same as the self-employed have no
guarantee of work at all
so will they still be in in the same
uh covering of this
policy i'd like them to i'd like to
think that the
the policy that's just been mentioned is
that you know not only the self-employed
but
it is those people that are on low hours
and they haven't got anything to to back
them
thank you if
we're starting to get into quite
complicated almost specific
uh details the number of hours in the
policy is set at 35
and that that that's at the core um i
think if if cancer stanley
wants a a further more detailed
answer on a very specific set of
circumstances
then i will pass over to uh
no no no me lucas thank you
naomi would you like to add anything
please
um thank you chair yeah the policy is
specifically
um the the minimum income floor does
specifically um apply
to self-employed people rather than
employed people
um as council stanley points out that
the the way that that is calculated is
based on an
equivalent minimum number of hours of 35
um and that isn't something we intend to
apply discretion on although as
councillor smith has
said we have got the discretion to um
vary the startup period to allow um
self-employed people a little
more leeway and we have been applying
that flexibility during the pandemic
um period um i would just add as i've
said in previous years that the
intention of the policy is that there is
some parity and fairness across those
who are
employed who may well be on low incomes
themselves
or even on zero hours um
against the self-employed so it's not um
that the council doesn't want to help
those that are self-employed but we want
to apply a policy that's fair and
consistent
across both cohorts of um of people and
that's the intention of the policy to be
fair
across across all of those groups thank
you
uh chairman you're a mute sorry members
can i remind everybody
that um we are debating uh the amendment
has put forward by uh councillor
hoy uh counselor mrs christine mason you
wish to speak
thank you mr chairman yes we are
debating a policy
and yet we're told we want to leave this
policy
to our staff which um and our members
will be doing that the staff members
were doing their best
by individuals i don't think that's fair
and either the individuals applying for
this
or for our staff members the
bureaucratic shortcomings that have been
mentioned should not be
end up with penalizing the disadvantaged
and if they are looking at situations
individually then there's no reason why
counselors hoy's amendments can't go
through if the government
in their wisdom have
altered this i'm surprised that an
administration of the same
colour wouldn't want to follow suit to
be honest
but my view is that the the very point
here is that we are disadvantaging
the already disadvantaged because of
this 35 hours
minimum floor so i will be supporting
the amendment
thank you
you're on mute gym sorry mrs mason
councillor thank you eves um just a
small point um it's been mentioned uh
many times in consideration
of support for self-employed people uh
the two-year
i mean although we're being flexible on
that if we are being flexible what is
the point of actually having the
two-year
in their case in point would be
something let's say for instance with
this year obviously you might have
people who've been self-employed in
business for many many years but they've
found themselves in hardship this year
because of the situation
um and i i'm finding it difficult to
understand
why we have a two-year
sort of standard on the uh the
the consideration that we are giving to
startups
when in actual fact what we're really
doing and what i've heard so far
is that we're we're considering it for
everyone so it just seems a little bit
strange
that we've got this two-year noted in
our policy
why would we do that if we don't if we
ignore it
routinely for people who actually need
it
thank you naomi lucas can you comment on
that
please um thank you chair yeah i
wouldn't
go as fast as we routinely ignore it i
think the intention of the policy is
that
if someone had just met that two-year
threshold for example
um as the pandemic started ordinarily
they wouldn't be
eligible to be considered but given the
pandemic
and the extraordinary circumstances um
some people may have found themselves in
we've
allowed officers that discretion and
flexibility to to
extend that if they if they see fit but
um
yeah so the two-year guideline is there
as a guideline as a starting point but
um obviously we have taken into account
the um
specific circumstances of individuals
over the course of the last
year and will intend to do so going
forward thank you
thank you lucas um members i can see no
other members wishing to speak
on the amendment um i shall therefore
put it to the vote i shall first ask
though
the four members who cannot raise their
hand icon whether they wish to have a
recorded vote and if once i call your
name if you could let me know
councillor mrs carter
thank you yes i would like a recorded
vote
bye
members angela law uh wishes to speak
chairman before you take this matter to
a vote we need to be clear as to
what the uh recommendation that council
foreign
however i do need council hoy to confirm
he's an amended recommendation
councillor hoy can you confirm that
please
uh yes a chairman i can confirm that
i have i believe stated it three times
yes i'm happy to confirm
um i'll just also point out that i did
have a right to reply but i chose not to
use it
thank you okay thank you
um councillor hoy chairman if i if i may
i just want to report a clarification i
just think it's important
for members the i think the reason that
angela's asking
is because paragraph 29 8.0
is nothing and it doesn't include all
the other paragraphs afterwards that
we've been discussing and i think that
might be the point that
angela is alluding to just for clarity
because at the moment
the only paragraph that we're going to
be voting on is just a
bold bit of text there's no paragraph to
it
sorry for for charity it was the whole
section 29a
that's what i thought but i just wanted
to clarify thank you very much
i was referring to a paragraph was the
wrong term
presumably it should be section 29
8.0 that whole section which is
headed minimum income floor that's
what's being removed
thank you for that council high and that
further clarification council wilkinson
council the hawkway
are you happy with that explanation
and do you still wish to second the the
amended motion
thank you chairman for asking yes
perfectly happy and i am
more than happy to continue second in um
the motion thank you
thank you very much members once again
then i shall
ask those members who are unable to
raise
their hand i accomplish that whether
they wish to have
a recorded vote council mrs carter
you've already indicated your wish
for a recorded vote is that still the
same please
thank you chair yes thank you councillor
hazelwood
no thank you councillor ionu
no recorded vote council merrick
no thank you members
um uh those members who wish to have a
recorded vote could you please
indicate by raising your hand icon
please
members there will not be a recorded
vote
um could i ask those the members please
once again
to indicate whether they wish to have a
recorded vote
and please only click on your icanned
icon once please
six
six yeah
members there will not be a recorded
vote thank you for your patience
sorry chairman can we please check the
math so i make it there's some
at least 20 i'll make it seven votes for
a recorded vote and there must be
there are 35 or fewer members present
we are checking again
members we've rechecked the figures and
there will be a recorded vote
when i call your name out please
indicate whether you wish
to vote for against or abstain
the amended motion as put forward by
councillor hoy
and seconded by councillor hookway
councillor mrs belton
against councillor mrs butcher
against thank you chairman councillor
mrs carter
thank you i support councillor michael
hoy's amendment
thank you councillor mr carter
against myself against
councillor fd
chairman i don't have an interest i am
self-employed so i'm not going to vote
on this
that's okay you wish you're abstain yes
yes
no no vote because abstain is
thank you councillor mrs gooding
against thank you chairman councillor
hazelwood
against council hazelwood you're on mute
council hazelwood you're a mute
please indicate
right i'm against thank you council
hookway
thank you chairman i am for the motion
council thank you chairman i'm for the
motion
thank you councillor hudson against
councillor ionu
for the motion uh chairman thank you
councillor
mr lucas gill again
thank you councillor mrs lumley
against against councillor mrs mason
mrs mason uh thank you mr chairman
i am supporting the motion to help our
disadvantaged self-employed
thank you mrs mcpherson
i am against the amendment i have faith
in the system that has already been in
place for our residents
thank you chairman councilman eric
councilman i'm against
chairman council newport
for the motion elsa pavling
thanks thank you chairman bouncing mrs
rowe
thank you chairman against councillor
mrs shaw
thank you chairman again councillor mr
shaw
against thank you council smith against
council sparing
against council stanley
for those thank you councillor steptoe
thanks thank you council ward
against council webb thank you chairman
i also have confidence in our existing
system
thank you again thank you council mrs
weston
against chairman council wilkinson
wish to restore chairman please
councillor williams
thank you chairman against council
wooden
against chairman thank you
thank you members
members that amended motion has been
defeated there were four
votes four sorry my apologies eight
votes for
24 against and two abstentions
thank you members
members we shall now debate the original
motion
as proposed by councillor smith and
seconded by
councillor uh wooden
um any questions members council
wilkinson
thank you chairman uh yes i have two
questions if i may just a bit of clarity
um section 3.1 of the report
it talks about a personal allowance um
and it says
that um there's an increase in this
personal allowance
is that does that mean there's an
increase in the allowance paid
or that the threshold required to meet
um
to qualify has increased um and my
second question is
regarding paragraph 5.2
which talks about officer's discretion
and i just wonder
what criteria has been decided will be
applied there and how does that work in
practice thank you chairman
thank you council wilkinson and naomi
lucas can you respond to those two
questions please
uh yes thank you chair um in relation to
councillor wilkinson's
um first question um on paragraph 3.1 of
the report
um he's correcting that that it's not an
amount
paid it's um it's an allowance used to
calculate the entitlement
to the local council tax support scheme
um in relation to his second query on
the hardship
fund um we do have some internal
guidance for
officers on those cases that we feel may
be eligible
for um for that scheme that that's not
um a kind of public document that's part
of this report
but yeah we do have some guidance but
ultimately um
as we said it it's officers who are
experienced and
you know um who are able to use their
discretion and to apply that
where necessary thank you
thank you uh naomi lucas uh councillor
laureen shaw
thank you chairman just for
clarification i was the one that
seconded us
councillor smith not uh council orton
thank you councillor mrs shaw and i
apologize for the error and thank you
for the
uh clarification thank you
members i can see no other members
wishing to
speak um on this um i shall therefore
put this to the vote
um and just to be clear
there are two recommendations
one these are on page 8.1 of the report
on page 13.3
one that the lcts scheme be approved to
come into effect from the first of april
2021 as detailed in section 13
a policy and two that the discretionary
reduction in council tax liability
policy
be confirmed from the first of april
2021
members i shall ask those who cannot
raise their raised hand
icon as if they wish to have a recorded
vote
for those recommendations council mrs
carter
thank you chair no i don't thank you
thank you councillor hazelwood
no thank you councillor ionu
uh no recorder but vote chairman thank
you counselor merrick
oh gentlemen thank you could i therefore
ask all the other councillors if they
wish to have a recorded vote
on this item please to indicate
members no one is indicating there will
not be a recorded vote
um could i ask therefore uh members who
are for the recommendation my apologies
members
i shall go to the four first uh
councillors who are unable to raise
their hand icon
to ask them if they are for against a
wish to abstain
uh from their recommendations counselor
mrs carter
thank you yeah i'd like to abstain
please on one and two
thank you council hazelwood whoa
thank you councillor ionu for the motion
chairman
thank you councilmerick poor chairman
thank you members could i ask the rest
of the members then
to indicate in a normal way as to
whether they are
for uh the motion please
chairman i'm sorry it's councillor lucas
gil my
uh computer won't raise the hand but i
am for
the motion
in future then council lucas gill i
shall add you to the four
who cannot raise their race hand is that
okay
uh yes thank you chairman sorry about
this
members if you could lower your rate
your blue hand icon please
members of those against please indicate
and those we wish to abstain please
indicate
members those recommendations have been
approved
27 votes for none against
seven abstentions thank you members
members we shall now take agender item
14
council representation on the
partnership panel
um this item uh will be introduced by
miss angela law assistant director
illegal and democratic
angela please
sorry sorry uh uh chairman you're you're
muted so we can't hear angela
my apologies members please continue
angela
thank you chairman the purpose of this
report is to ask members to review the
representation of the partnership panel
following a change in the political
composition of the council
paragraph 2.3 report shows the current
political composition as opposed to the
previous paragraph
so chairman the green and independent
group and the independent group have
been allocated a single seat between
chairman since the publication of the
report we have been informed that both
groups wish to
nominate councillor wilson therefore jeb
the recommendation we report
should now read that councilor wilson
should continue as a representative
on the partnership panel as per the
addendum
thank you thank you angela
any questions members
no one's indicating members we therefore
have one revised recommendations
as set out in the addendum to the report
on page 14.3
which i shall move from the chair and
that is that uh councillor s.a wilson
should continue as a representative on
the partnership
panel could i have a second to please
i'll second that chairman for you
chairman
thank you i think uh councillor ionu was
first
thank you very much members
members i shall therefore go to the vote
and i shall firstly ask those members
who cannot raise their
hand icon as if they wish to have a
recorded vote
councillor mrs carter
no thank you thank you councillor
hazelwood
no councillor ionu
no recorded vote chairman councillor
merrick
oh chairman councillor lucas gill
no chairman thank you thank you members
could i ask those
members wishing to have a recorded vote
to indicate now please
there is no such indication members
there will not be a recorded vote
therefore those members who uh wish to
agree to the recommendation please
indicate that
my apologies members i've done it again
i shall ask the members firstly
the ones who cannot raise their raised
hand icon
how they wish to vote councillor mrs
carter
thank you chair for thank you council
hazelwood
against councillor ionu
for council merrick
thank you councillor lucas gill four
thank you members could i ask the rest
of the members please to indicate those
who wish to
accept the recommendation please
members those recommendations have been
agreed 33 voted for one against
thank you
members i shall now take item 15 on the
agenda the crouch
harbour authority and again miss angela
law assistant director legal and
democratic will introduce this report
angela law
thank you chairman the purpose of this
report is to ask
members to approve a change in direct
representation to the crowd child
authority for the remainder of the
current municipal year
this this follows a change to the
membership of the executive
it is it is proposed that the castle
resolves that the portfolio holder for
the environment and place be appointed
as the council's representative on the
crouch harbor authority for the
remainder of the
municipal year thank you chairman thank
you angelo
members any questions at all on this one
please
there are none being indicated remembers
then we have one recommendation that's
set out in paragraph
7.1 of the report on page 15.1
which i will move from the chair this is
as follows
that the portfolio holder for the
environment and place be appointed as
the council's representative on the
crouch harbour authority
for the remainder of the municipal year
do i have a second of members please
i'll second that chairman
thank you councillor lucas gill
i shall now put this to the vote their
members
and i shall ask those members who cannot
raise their blue hand icon
whether they wish to have an a recorded
vote counselor mrs tony carter
thank you yes it's uh four thank you
is that for recorded vote counsellor mrs
carter
sorry chair i sorry i misheard that um
no i don't need a recorded vote sorry
councillor hazelwood would you like a
recorded vote
no councillor iodo
no recorded by chairman thank you
councillor merrick
no chairman and councillor mr lucas gill
no chairman thank you
um with the other members please indica
sorry please
indicate if they wish to have a recorded
vote
there's no such indication members could
those members then please
who wish to agree to the recommendation
uh pleasing uh my apologies
um if you could hold on for two seconds
members
um i shall first of all ask the members
who cannot raise their
hand icon how they wish to vote for
against her abstain counselor mrs carter
thank you chair for thank you councillor
hazelwood
council hazelwood
council hazelwood you can hear me
how would you wish to vote please
thank you councillor ionu
four chairman counselor merrick or
councillor lucas gill for
gentlemen members could i ask those
who members who are for the
recommendations to indicate please
come on
[Music]
time
you're a mute chairman chairman
thank you members i shall now take item
16 on the agenda
this is the paid policy statement 2021
stroke 22 the council's the council's
acting manager director mrs angela
hutchings will introduce the report
angela hutchins please
no sound coming through angela
angela hutchings are you with us
angela hutchins can i ask you to um uh
introduce item 16 please kevin can you
hear me i've had some problems
with my headphones today i can hear you
yes
apologies thank you members this report
comprises
the annual pay policy statement for the
financial year 2021-22
as required by the localism act 2011.
in line with the requirements of that
act the report sets out the council's
approach to remuneration of its
employees
and members will be familiar with the
detail contained within the report as it
follows the format of previous years
and if there are any questions i should
be pleased to answer them to the extent
that they are within my ability to do so
but if they are of a technical nature
with your permission chairman
i would provide a written answer outside
of this meeting
thank you engine members have
you any questions please
there is no such indication members
um members there is one recommendation
as set out
on paragraph 6.1 of the report on page
16.2 which i shall move from the chair
that the pay policy statement be adopted
do i have a second to please
i'll happily second that chairman thank
you council wilkinson
um members as usual i shall ask those
members
who are unable to raise their blue hand
icon whether they wish to have a
recorded vote
councillor mrs carter
thank you chair no i don't think he
council hazelwood
no council
no recorded vote chairman councillor
merrick
no councillor lucas gill
no chairman thank you uh those members
who
wish to have a recorded vote please
would they please indicate
members there will not be a recorded
vote
those members who wish to vote in favor
of the
before those members who wish to vote in
favor of the recommendation
i shall ask those members who are unable
to
raise their blue hand icon counselor mrs
mrs carter
thank you chair four thank you thank you
councillor hazelwood are you fall
against or abs wish to abstain
four councillor ionu
four chairman council merrick
or chairman councillor lucas gill
four chairman thank you uh
members those members who wishes do wish
to work
for the recommendation please indicate
that members has been agreed unanimously
so thank you very much and that
concludes the agenda for this evening
i therefore close the meeting and i
thank you for your
patience and forbearance as always at
21.04
thank you members